[Musica]
tra
grande allora io inizierei subito con
una domanda quanti tra voi utilizzano
abitualmente facebook sulle mani
riguardo benissimo giu
e adesso quanti tra voi almeno una volta
hanno preso per vero una notizia che
girava su facebook che ras tra condivisa
che era virale ma che poi si è rivelata
essere completamente falsa
sulle mani radio la vostra sincerità
fatevi un applauso bravi bravissimi
oggi il web e in particolare i social
network si scaraventano addosso una mole
incredibile di informazioni sono così
tante che per noi processarle e
metabolizzarle che è praticamente
impossibile
ecco perché il nostro approccio a tutto
quello che rappresenta
l'informazione online è superficiale e
sciatto è spesso viziato dai pregiudizi
molto spesso non ci prendiamo il tempo
necessario per processare un articolo in
maniera critica per esempio secondo voi
quante persone hanno preso per vero
questo articolo poche o tante l'articolo
è dell'ottobre del 2013
cécile kyenge era il ministro
dell'integrazione del governo letta in
italia abbia avuto un governo letta lo
dico per chi non se lo ricordi tipo
enrico letta
l'articolo il titolo dell'articolo
era questo che angie shock prendiamo
cani e gatti degli italiani per sfamare
gli immigrati ora secondo quello che
leggiamo un ministro della repubblica
italiana avrebbe detto pubblicamente
di prendere i vostri cani e gatti e di
dargli in pasto agli immigrati dando tra
l'altro per scontato che gli immigrati
mangiassero cani e gatti
fughiamo ogni dubbio
leggiamo qualche stralcio dell'articolo
prendiamo i cani e gatti degli italiani
per sfamare gli immigrati vi rendete
conto di quanti i salmoni vitelli polli
e selvaggina vanno a questi inutili
animali da compagnia è uno spreco
inaudito
sarebbe questa la dichiarazione shock
del ministro chi è riportata da
un'intervista a porte chiuse origliata
da un portantino che poi l'ha raccontata
alla moglie dell'autore volessimo sito
tutti i crimini degli emigrati punto com
che segue molto da vicino l'operato del
più cazzuto dei 38 fratelli kiehl's un
po pochino il dubbio ci viene
andiamo avanti non fanno in tempo e
anche a indignarsi quelli del
centrodestra che sempre mattinata un
altro autorevolissimo sito del calibro
di imola moggi riporta fedelmente una
nuova dichiarazione stavolta durante un
incontro con una famiglia rom disagiata
con solo due mercedes di cui una incinta
a cui il ministro ha voluto assegnare
come dimora e con utenze a carico del
comune la cinquecentesca villa medicea
di seravezza appena suo pre lido di
camaiore
ora abbiamo letto l'articolo
ne abbiamo riso ma credetemi non si sono
divertiti tutti google non si è
divertito in italia questi governanti
sono dei golpisti al servizio dei
criminali stragisti sionisti del
bilderberg stanno conducendo il popolo
italiano verso l'olocausto tra parentesi
quello vero è certo che questi flussi
migratori sono guidati dall arabia
saudita in combutta con israele
notoriamente grandi amici
porteranno il vento di guerra delle
primavere arabe in europa solo una
rivoluzione ci potrà liberare dal gioco
di questi criminali assassini dei popoli
e noi ci stiamo ancora chiedendo come un
esperto di politica internazionale del
calibro di google sia al momento
disoccupato
come potete leggere lì in alto
ma c'è di più pierluigi ora basta
ma chi si crede di essere questa
sottospecie di troglodita e non lo dico
per il colore della sua pelle
mettiamolo da parte non lo dice per il
colore della sua pelle ma per
l'annerimento della sua materia grigia
troppo distanti due tipi di cultura
quella italiana e quella africana non è
adatta al ruolo che ricopre la ministra
congolese e chi l'ha messa lì e meno
adatto di lei non vedete in che modo
ragiona l'unico interesse che ha è
quello di elevare i [ __ ] non lo dico
per il colore della sua pelle lo facesse
a casa sua e grazie al cazzo in concorso
tutti ne che chi vuoi elevare certi
comportamenti fanno diventare razzista
chi non lo è mai stato e noi ci scusiamo
per che alle 15 e 25 di quel 7 ottobre
2013 abbiamo fatto diventare pierluigi
razzista franco se è vera questa notizia
questa congolese ammessa in manicomio
ecco non so se leggete franco ha
studiato all'università bocconi
c'è riuscito a sbagliare il titolo è
riuscito a sbagliare il nome
dell'università dove presumibilmente ha
studiato si concede queste licenze
poetiche nei commenti ma mai come
francesco francesco mandatela ai forni
crematori lei e tutti quelli della su
dannatissima razza di imbecilli ora
francesco
è una persona che merita il nostro
rispetto perché riesce a dare
dell'imbecille una persona mettendo tre
errori di ortografia nella parola
imbecille
rosanna io mi riferisco alla chiesa
shock nome e cognome chiesto shock su
[Applauso]
sull'articolo di ammazzare gli animali
sia cani e gatti degli italiani che si
rimane vado in tutto perché in cinque
reti non c'è una virgola quindi e
fidatevi di me che si rimangi le parole
perché i nostri animali mangiano ossia i
croccantini ma dagli scarti dei macelli
eh no da animali vivi posso amare i
nostri cani e gatti noi non si mangia a
sbuffo come fa lei ed agli appartamenti
ai rom si vergogni se vuole agire
ritorni nella sua terra stronza faccina
triste perché poi è venuto un rimorso
così scrivendo abbiamo renata anche lei
non la prende benissimo se ha detto una
roba simile
ti vengo io a prendere brutta deficiente
troglodita vergognati sei una bestia
come tutti quelli che sbarcano in italia
ci state rovinando con la vostra cultura
di merda in fibula tori ignoranti
passano dieci minuti
comunque credo sia una bufala perché poi
il dubbio arriva ma non mi meraviglierei
se l'avesse detto a casa loro in fibula
know le bambine di 4 anni figurati se
non si mangerebbero un cane bestie
ed è anche in questo caso significativo
che renata si schieri dalla parte dei
cani e dei gatti dando delle bestie agli
immigrati
ora quello che abbiamo visto nei
commenti è un approccio all'informazione
molto superficiale e sciatto se vogliamo
è scellerato no in alcuni commenti
abbiamo visto a rasentare il cosiddetto
analfabetismo funzionale
quello che dobbiamo fare noi lettori e
tenere l'asticella dell'attenzione la
guardia sempre alta
dobbiamo prenderci il tempo necessario
per capire un articolo
e forse non soltanto noi lettori siamo
sempre nel 2010
questo è il terzo delle origini non so
se il titolo è questo errore
grazie il titolo è questo errore nel
sistema operativo radio maria passa i
megadeth quindi un gruppo metal ora
messo così il titolo sembra anche un po
trullo ne facciamo quello che abbiamo
fatto prima
leggiamo uno stralcio dell'articolo erba
è accaduto ieri intorno alle 13 e 30
nell intervallo pubblicitario del
programma a pranzo col corpo di cristo
improvvisamente il sistema operativo
della centrale radio a causa di un
errore umano è andato in tilt
l'emittente religiosa iniziato a
trasmettere brani dei megadeth cannibal
corpse system of a down che si trovavano
sulla chiavetta usb di uno dei
dipendenti mi sbarbo le palle a sentire
tutto il giorno preghiere si sarebbe
giustificato pio settimino è sempre la
solita cantilena in tutti i citofoni e
termosifoni della zona sono riecheggiati
brani ci sono i brani tra il terrore
delle persone anziane e il divertimento
dei trentenni
nel frattempo ha più settimino è stato
chiesto un risarcimento di 50 mila euro
e tre ave maria
ora seguitemi a pranzo col corpo di
cristo dio settimino canzoni che
riecheggiano nei termosifoni
risarcimenti di 50 mila euro e tre ave
maria
ecco io mi chiedo ma quale giornale
avrebbe potuto prendere per vera una
notizia del genere
ditemelo voi
libero la maggior parte dice libero
e invece a sorpresa e repubblica
repubblica xl che la sezione lifestyle e
cultura di repubblica poche ore dopo
esce con questo post su facebook
cose che capitano capitano stesse
repubblica il sistema operativo di radio
maria è andato in tilt ritrasmettendo
bene certamente poco amate dagli
ascoltatori e ci sono le band e gli
artisti erano presenti sulla chiavetta
usb di un dipendente che era attaccata
al computer principale ci sono le
canzoni
ora è caccia al nome del brut allaro
dell'emittente radiofonica votata a
maria
ora se vogliamo essere precisi il nome
del bruta allaro c'era ed era pio
settimino quindi l'articolo non l'hanno
neanche letto bene cosa succede succede
che poi tantissima gente inizia a
commentare sotto inizia a scrivere o ma
che cazzo fate con un post sul sito
satirico prendete per veri i loro
articoli e quindi repubblica appunto
come prescritto dalle rigide regole
della deontologia professionale
giornalistica calcio e le poste non
chiede scusa a nessuno
la notizia però aveva già fatto il giro
del web
tant'è che poco dopo deve smentirla
ufficialmente padre livio il direttore
di radio maria metal su radio maria non
risulta assolutamente il direttore
dell'emittente cattolica smentisce la
voce circolata in rete
secondo la quale martedì sarebbero
andati in onda bravi dei megadeth e dei
cannibal corpse e ci dispiace che padre
livio abbia appunto dovuto intervenire
sulla faccenda tra l'altro interrompendo
i suoi strali contro gli omosessuali
ora gli articoli diverso che abbiamo
visto non avevano l'obiettivo di
ingannare no
le abbiamo lette assieme li abbiamo
capiti ne abbiamo riso
eppure lettori e giornalisti li hanno
presi per veri ecco io mi chiedo ma se
soccombiamo davanti a una comicità che
così esplicita così genuina come
vogliamo sperare di cavarsela
di fronte a delle fec news delle bufale
che poi sono subito le somme spietate da
un grande potere derivano grandi
responsabilità
diceva ben parker no lo zio di spider
man il web il social network ci danno un
grandissimo potere
ognuno di noi può creare dei contenuti
può parlare a un pubblico che è
potenzialmente vastissimo può aumentare
la portata di una notizia semplicemente
condividendo la semplicemente pigiando
un bottone ha però anche delle grandi
responsabilità della mole incredibile di
informazione che ci investe siamo noi a
decidere cosa tenere e cosa no cosa far
nostro e cosa no paradossalmente
decidiamo tra quello che è vero è quello
che è falso
se usiamo bene il nostro potere
potremmo essere i nodi di una rete
virtuosa che diffonde conoscenza e
verità
se lo usiamo male saremo le metastasi di
un cancro che inquina e chi avvelena
ecco io ho deciso cosa voglio essere
e voi grazie
[Applauso]